hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to put
medication into a medication cup for
oral medication administration so let's
get started when administering
medications you want to make sure that
you follow your hospitals protocols
because they may have specific sequences
for how they want you to administer
medications first gather your supplies
perform hand hygiene and the medication
administration rights i've confirmed the
physician's order with what i have on
hand so the physician has ordered 700
milligrams by mouth once a day of fake
elixir and on hand i'm looking at my
medication label and it says i have fake
elixir and it's an oral solution and in
this bottle whenever i measure it out
five milliliters contains 350 milligrams
well i need to administer 700 milligrams
so i'm going to administer 10
milliliters and you can look on your
little medicine cup and find 10
milliliters now whenever you're
administering liquid oral medications
you want to make sure you're using the
device that came with the medication or
what was supplied from pharmacy and many
times patients are going to be going
home on these medications so you want to
educate them to use the device that came
with the medication instead of some
household spoon that they might use like
a tablespoon or a teaspoon because that
could provide the wrong dose so prior to
pouring the medication in the cup you
want to look at the black lines on the
cup it will tell you what the
measurement is for example we have 5
milliliters 10 milliliters and 15
milliliters we are ordered to give 10
milliliters so i'm going to fill the cup
up to that line however in some
measuring devices the fluid may curve
upwards on the sides due to surface
tension if that's the case you'll want
to make sure the bottom part of the
curve meets the measurement line also
you want to make sure the medication
doesn't need to be shaken before you
pour it because many times like
suspensions they need to be shaken
before you actually pour them into the
cup because you need to mix the
medication up evenly in the solution
that's in so this medication does say
shake well before you so we're going to
give it a really good shake before we
pour it
after shaking the medication you want to
remove the cap from the bottle so twist
it off
and you want to place it in a secure
location so you don't just knock it off
and place it so the cap opening is
pointing up so the bottom of it doesn't
become contaminated on the surface
you're working with when pouring the
medication into the cup you want to make
sure that you have it on a flat sturdy
level surface rather than holding and
pouring because whenever you're holding
and pouring you could maybe have the cup
a little bit tilted and it could throw
off the measurement when you're ready to
pour the medication you want to make
sure that you hold this bottle in a way
that protects this label from medication
dripping on it and then obscuring like
the dosage and other people and yourself
can't read it so you want to hold the
bottle where your hand is going to be
covering this label to protect it so
make sure the label is upward take your
hand and just cover it like so and hold
it like this when you're ready to pour
in addition whenever you're pouring you
want to make sure that you bend down and
look at the cup straight on so that your
angle of view doesn't distort the
measurement as you pour the medication
into the cup do it slowly until it
becomes even with the black line now
let's say that you overfill it well what
you can do is discard the extra
medication per your facilities protocols
but don't attempt to add it back to the
bottle because this could cause
contamination of the medication that's
in the bottle once you're done pouring
you want to make sure that you take a
dry clean napkin and just clean the top
of the opening of the bottle because
this is going to help prevent any
buildup on the bottle from happening
because from my experience i have seen
crusted medication just build up at the
end of this bottle plus it'll leak down
and just dry on that medication label
and what can happen is that that crust
can actually fall into your medication
cup and contaminate it once you've done
that you want to take the cap and you
want to place it back on the bottle and
tightly secure it on there and check it
make sure it's in place and then you
want to store the medication according
to the medication labels instructions
this medication needs to be refrigerated
so that is where we can store it and
some medications can be stored at room
temperature but always check now before
administering you want to again perform
the medication checks and you want to
perform hand hygiene and dawn gloves
then assist the patient into an upright
position to swallow the medication after
the patient has taken the medication you
want to dispose of the cup or if you
need to keep the cup because it's used
for multiple doses you want to clean it
with warm soapy water and let it
completely air dry and then return it to
the patient's medication bottle once
that's complete you want to doff your
gloves perform hand hygiene and document
okay so that wraps up this demonstration
on how to put medication into a cup and
if you'd like to watch more nursing
skill videos you can access the link in
the youtube description below